President Trump says he spoke with
Ukraine's leader about one of his
strongest rivals in the 2020 campaign
that's former Vice President Joe Biden
he did not confirm or deny that he asked
for an investigation of Biden's son and
his business interest in Ukraine
published reports say though that the
President did exactly that and House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi called that a
serious possible breach of
constitutional duties she said any
effort by the White House to withhold
information would mark in her words a
grave new chapter of lawlessness Paula
Reid is at the United Nations traveling
with the president big week Paula but
also big controversy how is this
expected to play out at the UN good
morning Gail the most anticipated event
on the president's schedule this week is
his conversation with the leader of
Ukraine this comes amid controversy over
reports the president pressured his
Ukrainian counterpart to investigate the
Biden family on Sunday President Trump
defended a July phone call with the
president of Ukraine where he discussed
former Vice President Joe Biden the call
has come under scrutiny after a whistle
blowers complained to the intelligence
community's Inspector General according
to The Wall Street Journal during the
call mr. Trump urged the Ukrainian
leader eight times to investigate the
Biden family acclaim the Ukrainian
foreign minister backed denying there
was any coercion but Democrats are
calling for renewed scrutiny into the
Trump administration's recent release of
military aid to Ukraine there are likely
a bunch of different explanations
political pressure was mounting on the
president from Republicans but obviously
the timing of this looks really terrible
on Twitter and in statements the
president has been suggesting Biden
improperly used his position as vice
president to help out his son in 2016
while Vice President Biden threatened to
withhold 1 billion dollars in American
loan guarantees unless the Ukraine
dismissed its top prosecutor who is seen
as being lacks on corruption
Biden's son hunter served on the board
of a company that had previously come
under scrutiny by the prosecutor there
is no evidence that the former vice
president or his son acted
inappropriately in a rare letter to
Democrats and Republicans House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi warned of a whole new stage
of investigation if the Trump
administration continues to conceal the
whistleblowers complaint the president
says he will consider releasing a
transcript of the call later this week
the Acting Director of National
Intelligence will testify on Capitol
Hill about that whistleblower complaint
that so far has been withheld from
lawmakers Anthony Paula thank you